[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today marks in
Nashville hey Mark how are you
I'm fantastic how are you doing today
better than I deserve what's up
uh well I'm calling in to ask uh if it's
a good decision or a short-sighted
decision to cash out what happened my
401k thus far that I was contributing to
before I started on the baby steps in
order to pay off my student loans faster
hmm
how much is in your 401k
uh not like a ton I have about 27 and a
half and I used an online calculator
that said that if I after penalties and
everything I'd get about 20 19 or 20.
yeah you get hit a 10 penalty plus your
tax rate so it'll be somewhere between
30 and 40 percent of it goes to the
government for taking it out early so
it's kind of like saying Dave I want to
borrow money at 35 interest to pay all
my student loans
nope Niche nope nope
not doing that one
no we don't Cash Out retirement early to
pay debt and because of that it's just
the the cost is too high
so um so how much student loan debt have
you got
I've got about 7
50 now what do you make
about 50
000 a year good how much is your car
payment
I don't have one I bought a car cash
good good for you what other debts have
you got other than the 56 000 student
loan
um I have a small medical debt but uh
that's it okay good you single
I sure am yeah okay all right
well what I would do if I woke up in
your shoes my sir my friend is I would
um roll up my sleeves and attack it with
an absolute Vengeance because I have
found in 30 years of doing this that the
faster you get out
the more likely you are to get out and
uh the people who try to bump along and
half butt you know keep it around like
it's a pet they don't make it out and so
I'm gonna go just like crazy like where
my broke friends think I joined a cult
crazy right I'm going nuts like nothing
I'm not going out to eat I'm not going
on vacation I'm gonna pick up three
extra jobs and we'll sell everything in
sight and if you put 25 000 a year on
this you'll be done in two years but
that's you living on nothing if you uh
put 30 on it you'll be done in 14 15 16
months that's because you're working
extra and living on nothing but that's
the kind of thing I'm saying is just
take a an 18-month period of time and go
berserk and be done with this otherwise
it's gonna be around for 10 years
yeah I completely agree I mean in in 10
years of paying it I barely made a dent
so you can't you can't you just can't
get rid of them they're just it's like a
bad mother-in-law joke I mean you just
it's awful so Mark fun question here all
right and I want you to be conservative
but I want you to to throw a number at
me if you really got after it extra jobs
selling stuff I mean just really intense
like Dave said what do you think is the
number you could come up with the amount
of money that you could throw at this
loan could you do 2 000 a month fifteen
hundred three thousand I mean you really
went after what's the number you think's
realistic
yeah doing some of those calculations I
think what I landed on was that the
absolute Max before I'm starting to have
to cut into bills or like get the
internet turned off is about 1800 a
month that's without you making any
extra money
correct yeah that's like if I'm paying
rent and that's it yeah that's what do
you continue to do for a living
I work for uh I'm an I.T professional
for an eyeglass company okay freelance
work my man like how much money could
you make with your it skills yeah
Contracting additional money Contracting
workout in the evenings oh my gosh dude
yeah I've never looked into that I don't
know anything about freelancing I.T
three or four thousand bucks a month
that's your homework assignment easy
look at your skill set all the search
you have you know your world better than
we do but I'm telling you you've done it
you've done an unusually good job for
someone who's new to this material that
we teach you know this is fair this
whole Ramsay thing's fairly new to you
so I can tell by the way you're talking
but the uh and that's not bad but you've
done an unusually good job of analyzing
your situation and you've already cut
deep if you could get two thousand a
month out of your budget and put three
on top of it that's five you're done in
10 12 months dude yep that's the
exercise the beauty of this whole call
is you've got an untapped Reservoir
called it side jobs that's going to pay
really good it might even open up a
career for you that you didn't even know
you had advancement in this in this
thing it's absolutely incredible so Ken
this student loans are top of mind right
now because they're starting they're
going to start paying them again in
October that's right and um
you know the first thing that happened
was there was false hope people have
kind of gone through the um the stages
of grief
right it's really false hope that Biden
was going to forgive the debt and then
once the false hope and it was false yep
those of us that know a little bit about
it told you it was false but that people
held out anyway okay false hope now then
it turned to anger
but you know and our denial anger
and now it's moving to fear sure
because I'm looking up and I've got 900
a month I'm gonna start saying in
October and I'm going to have to work in
extra jobs and I'm not gonna see my kids
and I'm scared